l'une des plus grandes mobilisations
sociales depuis 50 ans dans toutes les
territoires dans toutes les villes quel
que soit leur taille les Français vous
ont hurlé le rejettent cette réforme oui
nous sommes dans une situation de
blocage démocratique et pourtant il y a
quelques mois ici ici la première
ministre Élisabeth borne était venu nous
dire son discours de politique générale
et elle nous avait dit entre autres ceci
nous consulterons plus encore les corps
intermédiaires les forces vives de notre
pays les Françaises et les Français de
chaque territoire plus que jamais nous
mènerons chaque réforme en lien étroit
avec les organisations syndicales six
mois plus tard elle présentait ce projet
de loi
avec son mépris elle a créé une intercer
syndicale historique qui a construit un
mouvement social exemplaire massif
déterminé et pacifique pour l'instant
parce que les seuls alliés qu'elle a
trouvé ils étaient ici dans cette Haute
Assemblée c'est le groupe LR fidèle à
ses idéaux réactionnaires qui a servi de
buen sauvetage au gouvernement
complice du tour de force démocratique
mais la majorité sénatoriale depuis 4
jours a choisi en grande partie le
silence moi je vois des collègues ici
ils ont passé quatre jours dans un
fauteuil à lever la main en suivant les
consignes de vote du gouvernement
pourtant vous le devez aux Français
expliquer pourquoi pourquoi les Français
vont devoir trimer deux ans de plus
expliquez-leur pourquoi vous avez
toujours voulu épargner les plus
favorisés et parmi les super profiteurs
de crise et parmi la rente épargner le
capital depuis trois jours alors ici
dans la chambre des territoires on va
vous demander une chose entendez les
millions des voix qui sont élevés dans
toutes les villes dans tous les villages
dans tous vos territoires et renoncer à
cette réforme brutale et tellement
injuste